[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner toten wird
heute möchte ich euch ein blättchen
rezept vorstellen und zwar sinn des
schokoladen man die plätzchen und was
ihr an zutaten benötigt zeige ich euch
jetzt ihr benötigt 100 gramm
zartbitterschokolade wie müsst ihr
vorher schmelzen und etwas abkühlen
lassen
300 gramm mehl 200 g weiche butter eine
prise salz in größe m einen halben
teelöffel zimt 100 gramm puderzucker und
50 gramm gemahlene mandeln die zutaten
die kommen jetzt alle zusammen in einer
schüssel
[Musik]
wenn alle zutaten dann in der schüssel
sind da rührte sie mit dem elektrischen
handmixer und zwar braucht ihr da diese
knethaken
[Musik]
den teilt solltet ihr jetzt abdecken und
für eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
stellen und danach geht's gleich weiter
anhalten stunde nehmt ihr euch den teig
aus dem kühlschrank moment mit hilfe von
zwei teelöffeln steckt ihr dann etwas
teig ab und gebt den einfach auf das
backpapier und das muss auch überhaupt
nicht ordentlich sein die kekse
verlaufen dann und das geht dann ganz
zum schluss ganz toll aus und das macht
jetzt so mit dem kompletten tag last
aber etwa einen teig breite platz
zwischen drin
[Musik]
wieder die plätzchen fertig habt werden
sie bei etwa 180 grad 12 bis 15 minuten
gebacken wenn die plätzchen gebacken
sind nehmt ihr sie heraus und lasse er
vor einem kuchengitter auskühlen
wenn die kekse dann abgekühlt sind nehmt
ihr euch geschmolzene zar peter kober
türe
da brauchte er etwa 150 gramm die sonne
temperiert sein das heißt sie darf nicht
zu heiß sein aber auch nicht zu kalt
das zeige ich euch doch mal in einem
anderen video wie das geht und dann
nehmt ihr euch einfach einen und tauchte
ihn zur hälfte in die schokolade ein nas
kurz abtropfen ist nichts mehr läuft
und dann gibt die ihn zum abkühlen auf
euer gitter und ich habe da jetzt noch
einen glas zähler drunter und da kann
dann die schokolade die noch ab tropf
drauf laufen
[Musik]
wenn ihr nun alle plätzchen mit
schokolade überzogen habt lasst ihr sie
abkühlen und aushalten
und dann sind sie eigentlich auch schon
fertig und können serviert werden am
besten bewahrt ihr sie in einer box auf
und das ist dann auch mehrere tage bis
wochen haltbar und jetzt wünsche ich
euch viel spaß danach machen und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]